hey here's an interesting voicemail we
didn't get to cover this story but in
research Fort Lee before Roy Moore was
defeated in Alabama last Tuesday he was
asked about he and his wife were asked
about whether they might be her his wife
about whether there it might be
anti-semitic or something like that and
she said no we're not because we have a
Jewish lawyer that's evidence that were
not in it was actually part of a planned
speech she had this written down yeah to
those who say we're anti-semitic we have
a Jewish lawyer so we got this really
funny voicemail about that comment take
a listen
hey David so I think that saying that
I'm not anti-semitic I have a Jewish
lawyer is the new I'm not racist I have
a black friend right
yeah I think that there's something to
that yeah you couldn't and there's
because there's this sort of
undercurrent of anti-semitism in terms
of the good things about Jews it's very
common that people genuinely think I
love Jews
I would only hire a Jewish lawyer they
think that it's some kind of praise but
it's the same type of stereotyping and
judging of a population in total based
on the career choice of the few it's
still these it's still the same type of
a stereotyping that we talk about with
lots of other groups yeah even though
so-called positive stereotypes
yes something badly about those who
don't fit that stereotype within that
group no doubt about it
so yes I think that there is something
to that you can leave your voicemails at
two one nine to david p we've got a
great bonus show for you today we will
speak to you in mere minutes on that
members-only bonus show